gather round for the week fourteen  playoff picture how do you all like your  sweaters get out of my way mahomes hey  if y'all can just behave I'll buy LG  french fries okay I can do this I think  you all will fit from my there's white  wait date clearly well uh Erin it  doesn't look like you're in I could just  get a little help okay well if we'd be  the Falcons and the Bears and the Jets  and of course Dean the Seahawks and the  Vikings will lose out and the Bears just  stop playing football  wait where's the NFC's sorry everybody I  think the Cowboys are in you stole my  sweater what what you doing little guy  I'm trying to make a playoff push oh  come on whit take control okay so I can  tell you I don't like that wait where do  you think bucks out great job everybody  else Seabreeze yeah I guess if the rest  of the NFC loses we might make it in so  I don't know probably have no chance but  at least you might as well subscribe and  like this channel it's all I got